ladies and gentlemen Goku's and go cats
Vegeta's and vagitine ease guys we
finally made it over mountains of
garbage and through oceans of [ __ ] after
waiting around for awkwardly paced
motion tweens the finally end we find
ourselves on the precipice of
mouth-watering boner bouncing jump out
of your bed at 3:00 and screaming bloody
murder
awesomeness take a good look behind you
at what we've gone through together guys
because it's on to bigger and better
things today that's right
call amazing because this arc was
[ __ ] it I'm totally not mark and
these are the 10 best animated moments
of Dragon Ball super is universe 6 Ark
number 10 Frost
you little rascal topping off our list
comes one of many moments that made my
inner fangirl go animated by UK hero
katana it might not be the most
consistent entry but this took me on an
emotional roller coaster that I won't
forget anytime soon but I'm gay ahead of
myself here so let's break this mother
down after transforming into his assault
form frost and Goku go toe to toe
leading to this tasty little cut where
frost tacos Goku through his own
Kamehameha which was such a sweet idea
whoever thought that deserves a medal or
cake give them cake this then ultimately
leads to Goku transforming into his
regular blond Super Saiyan form frost
powers up in response and quickly zooms
in to punch Goku as fast as he can
giving us justice sexy as [ __ ] shot of
Goku catching frost punch this next part
might not be solely animation centric
but it's interesting sociation when
watching this episode for the first time
I enjoyed all this action but I could
never have predicted the way it was
going to end after dominating the entire
fight with ease Goku blocks what appears
to be a flimsy punch from frost seconds
later
Goku suddenly loses his composure and
then gets knocked out of the ring by
Frost guys our first viewing of this I
was completely floored I mean I was like
I've been two minutes later I was all
like mm and I wasn't the only one this
sparked tons of conversation in the
comments section of both Reddit and
youtuber like discussing what exactly
happened by the time the next episode
swung around most had a decent grasp of
what exactly was afoot but many didn't
want to believe it
then Frost turn around and gave us this
shot this is the moment for frost in the
tournament I think that moment you
realize he was playing all of us this
whole time
who Frost's you cold customers number
nine piccolo vs frost my heart having
just recovered from the betrayal it
received courtesy of frost comes this
next entry in her account Oh
Goku having been eliminated means that
next up the fight on behalf of universe
7 is piccolo many of us watching this
fight didn't think piccolo had any
realistic chance and I for one was
really impressed with how the writers
orchestra is this sequence in a
believable and interesting way while it
might not be the prettiest fight the
choreography and choices in the
animation sequences are what make this
entry
quite good animated by Yoshitaka yeah
Sheila we see some interesting aerial
animation and some moves we hadn't seen
in so long laser beam eyes the
afterimage technique stretchy green arms
it was an insert winder of how cool it
was for this tournament to not be a
sayin fest Frost does go on to Chief to
gain the upper hand but this led to this
moment which was just for me I see the
scene Gail out of flack but I loved it
number 8 the filler with flair for our
8th position in this list we are taking
a break from the tournament to see some
nice slice of life stuff you know
Bulma calling her sister who is suddenly
a thing an alien on vacation and a deity
from another universe making burger
stands with his blue attendant you know
typical stuff these three moments from
episode 29 had some nice little caveats
when it came to animation I think Osama
Ishikawa was the animation supervisor
for this episode which featured this
Oh
jaco spaceship seems to get some nice
treatment here too with this nice smoke
trail and take off its both clean and
smooth for me it was one of many
indications that this Ark looked much
more polished than its predecessors and
then there was this scene with champa
and vados short but nice this scene
showcases some nice explosion number 7
beerus and champa meet i think my
favorite part of Dragon Ball super is
the new cast of characters we have slash
are being introduced to beerus Champa
Wiese and vados are some of my favorite
characters from Dragon Ball Dragon Ball
Z and Dragon Ball super combined vados
however has a special place in my heart
the amount of [ __ ] talk she throws as
Champa is hysterical I'd like to put
forward a formal proposal for battles as
Dragon Balls best girl vote in the
comment section down below hashtag best
girl battles I with these new characters
being introduced to the main series plot
it was great to see them do it with some
great animation the animation was
supervised by the talented Yoshitaka
yeah she may be some great dust clouds
and explosions from these two and
explosive personalities we also got to
see some interesting silhouette
animation too it's a fun scene made
better with some great animation and
snark from vados but mostly animation
number 6 Vegeta and Goku vs hit no not
this scene this scene keep your pants on
animated by Naoki Tata this scene
features some of the great art work we
have come to expect from Tata and it
featured possibly the best-looking Super
Saiyan blue power up for Vegeta in this
series so far I didn't much care for
this one although this scene did have
moments that I didn't care for primarily
this exchange featured great new angles
we aren't used to seeing and these
over-the-top facial expressions Naoki is
slowly becoming famous for the same can
be said for Goku's portion of this
episode
interesting fun action sequences with
simple to understand objectives are the
key to why this episode was so
successful I think the objective being
land a hit on his then I had never been
so invested in a scene before as is
always the case with Tata his work the
movements are fluid and full of
personality energy surges through this
man's pet in a way that is unpredictable
and unique
certainly his biggest strengths number
five Jaakko takes out burp man one can
find greatness in the most unlikely of
places just look at this design it's
spectacular in this episode which was
created exclusively for exposition how
about them super Dragon Balls a we find
ourselves following Jocko and Bulma as
they venture in search of information
regarding the super Dragon Balls this
leads them to a person called Sudha who
knows everything and if that isn't the
most lazy plot device I don't know what
is they venture to his lovely abode only
to find that a convict that the Galactic
Patrol are looking for is there Jaakko
being a galactic patrolman is forced to
intervene and I have to say is [ __ ]
awesome this was one of those episodes
where I was kind of half watching but as
soon as that happened I just stopped
everything and gave the remainder of the
show but undivided attention which I'm
sure was the desired result seeing as
all the information regarding the super
Dragon Balls was vomited onto the screen
there after he got me Joey you got me
number four Jocko the expressive one in
the world of animation scenes of action
and violence aren't the only times
animation can shine it can help yes
but they aren't necessary some of my
favorite kinds of animation come from
expression and the conveyance of emotion
getting a character over in a short
amount of time is the Mac of a great
animated this scene doesn't feature a
punch it doesn't contain a beam or a
flicker from a transformation this is
simply Jacko talking to the camera and
Aoki today made this visually stunning
somehow booming with personality and
energy
Jaco leaps through our screens in this
moment and although brief it was yet
another time in this show where Naoki
Tata demonstrated his skills as an
animation marvel number three the
Cheetahs Gallic gun and final flash now
the we're at the business end of the
list coming in at number three is the
nostalgia Express featured in episode 36
we see Vegeta having difficulty putting
magenta away running out of air space
and options the cheetah
puts his hands into this position and we
all know what this means the gallic gun
now I have to admit upon seeing this
pose I had my reservations about whether
or not Tony could in fact pull off one
of the most iconic beams Vegeta has
flashbacks to the Tina's confrontation
with beer it's in episode 8 I just
didn't want it to be another lifeless
effort from the chena Oh but man I
wasn't in the least bit disappointed
with this one swooping from his eyes
through his scream to wide-angle view
this was a gorgeous shot of the Saiyan
Prince building from that moment comes
this blast from the past finally we see
the final flash return and holy hell
does it come back in a big way the
electricity for me was the highlight of
this sequence cutting through the arena
like a hot knife through butter
the cheetah powers up his ultimate
attack as lightning envelops the empty
world
it was animated by one of the best
animators in Toy today mr. Misha
Hiroshima nuki the colors fantastic the
character models impeccable the
animation exciting this was a
spectacular scene amidst a thrilling
battle deserving of its place as my
number 3 number 2 the universe 6 arc
intro sequence falling short of our
number 1 spot comes this snippet from
the intro sequence of the universe 6 are
animated by Ken Otsuka this is action
animation at its finest encapsulating
perfectly the ride we are about to go on
with this arc not once that ever failed
to get me pumped up for this tournament
brimming with power and energy this
intro sequence featured every member of
the universe 6 team collating with this
gentlemen for me this unveiling had me
eager to learn more about this
mysterious hit character little did I
know what was awaiting for me once this
acts final match between hit and Goku
began not ecology of course Monachus
fight with it because let's be real it
wasn't really a fight hit there's no
chance now on to the main event number 1
kaio-ken times 10 this moment was
special many of you probably don't know
this but I'm actually from Ireland as a
result need to stay up until 1:00 a.m.
in order to watch Dragon Ball super life
the scene in question began with Goku
describing this technique he had been
perfecting for his next clash with
beerus and she goes on to describe it I
start getting a suspicion but I don't
think anything of it then it happens the
Super Saiyan blue aura becomes shrouded
in a familiar fiery red life as Goku
exclaims kaio-ken like in my bed my eyes
widened as I listened and washed on as
my favorite move in Dragon Ball history
had finally made a return to the silver
screen
Goku explains that the only reason
he was able to use this move in the
first place was due to Super Saiyan
blues key control as opposed to regular
Super Saiyan which would have almost
certainly torn his body into pieces when
coupled with the kaio-ken this moment
was amazing and the best part was it
made complete sense but this scene
wasn't done yet
oh no not by a long shot Goku begins to
power up hit astonish and what he is
seen comments on how much more powerful
Goku is becoming 2 times stronger 3
times he says until Goku finally screams
times 10 Goku himself the arena and the
whole screen glow a powerful red as the
intensity of the scene is increased
Goku explodes forward with a gorgeous
punch that ends in slow motion upon
contact the intro music Shou so dynamic
begins to play to add to the hype trim
Goku meets hit with a flurry of punches
and kicks before ultimately outpacing
his time skill as hit flies upward
Goku's aura pulsates as he soars through
the air he realizes he doesn't have much
time left so he channels all his power
into an enormous kamehameha to cap off
the episode animated by Tara Yoshi
Yamamoto and kala suka this scene really
rejuvenated Dragon Ball super for a lot
of people and for many is the mark of
when Dragon Ball super really kicked it
up enough and I do not disagree with
that sentiment in the slightest this
scene was nothing short of amazing in my
opinion and stands up to tons of Dragon
Ball Z's very best this is a scene still
talked about today and I'm sure it will
be for many more years to come
in that moment as I was lying in bed I
got goosebumps and my eyes widened as I
watched this match unfold I didn't see
it coming
it ended the tournament with a bang and
was for me the very best moment of the
entire universe 6 ark and the series up
until this point but little did we know
what was in store for us next if you
guys would like to see more top 10s and
analysis subscribe to be the first to
know when I release a new video also
don't forget to leave a comment on what
your favorite moments are I'd love to
read them I've been totally not mark and
this has been the 10 best animated
moments of Dragon Ball super is universe
6 arc thank you so much for watching